la frappe a soufflé une grande partie de
cet immeuble il est 5 heures du matin de
nombreuses familles dorment est encore
dans leur appartement peut-être par
lassitude d'aller aux abris peut être
aussi parce qu'il n'imagine pas que ce
quartier résidentiel sera la cible d'une
attaque russe
je me suis réveillé à 5 heures du matin
je suis allé dans la cuisine prendre un
verre d'eau coup et j'ai vu un flash de
lumière pour voitures après j'étais
recouverte aux d'éclats de verre
je me suis abrité derrière le mur
mais j'avais des coupures par tout
temps changent je suis en colère car il
ya des victimes
je suis en colère contre tous les
responsables
une personne en partie
[Musique]
sous le choc des résidents qui ont
quitté la ville depuis plusieurs jours
et reviennent récupérer quelques
affaires avec le sentiment de l'avoir
échappé belle
j'habite au rez de chaussée si on avait
été là on serait tous morts
je ne sais pas quand tout ça va se
terminer j'en peux plus je veux juste la
fin de ce cauchemar
le maire de kiev est arrivé pour
constater l'étendue des dégâts et
interpeller le monde avec théo sortu des
gens chaque jour chaque minute j'ai un
message pour la communauté
internationale
s'il vous plaît aidez lucre et ce matin
il flotte un sentiment de colère les
civils étaient selon ce militaire
délibérément visé une zone résidentielle
il n'y a aucune cible militaire la liane
nicole l'alien stade
c'en est trop pour certains ils quittent
la capitale ukrainienne